il s'appelle céline en référence à l'une
des collaboratrices du projet et
marraine de la machine le premier
tunnelier de la ligne 18 a été baptisé
ce mardi 14 septembre à palaiseau un
événement fait selon les traditions
c'est une somme de travail assez
considérable qui permet d'aboutir à
cette inauguration elle est symbolique
aussi parce que il se trouve que les
tunneliers sont des professions dur et
qui attache beaucoup d'importance aux
traditions mais il faudra encore
patienter quelques semaines pour que la
première pierre soit brisée par
l'immense machine les simples opérations
de montage un tunnelier qui fait 100
mètres de long les milliers de tonnes
sont des opérations très complexe qui
sont évidemment mené en lien avec les
ingénieurs de la société qui fabrique ce
tunnelier prévue pour 2026 cette
première portion entre orly et palaiseau
est bel et bien en route le début de 35
km de métro automatique qui passera dans
les yvelines dans les yvelines en aura
plusieurs séquences on a une partie la
ligne 18 qui en aérien donc la
technologie sera différente c'est
quelque chose de beaucoup plus simple on
aura une partie en tranchée couverte qui
sera creusé depuis la surface et puis on
aura une partie en tunnels creusés au
tunnelier entre saint quentin s est le
terminus de la ligne 18 en 2030 qui sera
versée chantier pour la portion
yvelinoise du projet et les gares de
saint quentin est satory et versailles
chantiers il faudra encore patienter les
travaux dans les yvelines commenceront
en 2023 petite vitesse d'abord et
prendront leur essor vraiment imprévue
les jeux olympiques de 2024 donc le mois
d'octobre 2024 le tunnelier devrait
démarrer dans ces eaux là la ligne 18
finalisé entièrement en 2030 prévoit 110
milles voyages quotidiens à travers les
yvelines l'essonne et les hauts-de-seine